Delphine lorsque la saison dernière vous
aviez pris des positions très tranchées
nous vous avons laissé tomber j'ai
essayé Cyril vous a soutenu j'ai essayé
de vous soutenir et vous m'avez dit un
jour mais Gilles quand tu parlais ton
langage corporel de trahisset tu n'avais
pas l'air de croire en ce que tu disais
et bien je m'en excuse j'ai pas été
assez clair Delphine vous avez eu le
mérite de de prendre des positions
claires fortes et j'aurais dû plus être
à vos côtés maintenant je serai avec
vous
voulez vous faire la paix avec moi c'est
très beau et Gilles donc tu soulèves
quand même et tu me tu me tu ravives des
souvenirs en moi et c'est vrai que à
cette période là où clairement tout le
monde m'avait lâché
je crois savoir que j'ai donné une
interview qui disait quand on a des
collègues comme ça on n'a pas besoin
d'ennemis alors tout simplement pour
cette période et à tous
[Applaudissements]